we're now going to move on to this big
multi-part question
that leads off question six so before we
start to have a look at the solutions
let's just get a sense of the overall
question and try and sense like what
direction is it headed in
and how can all the parts all fit
together so it begins like this
using the exponential form of a complex
number so we've seen before that
different forms of complex numbers
are more suitable for solving different
kinds of problems or
proving different kinds of results the
particular result being focused on in
this question part one is
show that z times its conjugate z bar is
equal to
the modulus of z or squared and hence
simplify
z plus w and z plus w
bar so you can see there's a clear
parallel between
this here which is the product of a
complex number z plus w
with its conjugate compared to this
result over here
where it's the same thing it's just z
bar instead of z plus w
z plus w bar okay so there's the first
thing let's keep on moving and see if we
can understand you know this is the kind
of thing that i use
reading time for to understand how all
the different parts of the question fit
together
because of course when you're solving
something you want to know
the trajectory and where you're going to
take it because that's often very useful
for what you're going to do beforehand
it then says using the rectangular form
of a complex number so now we're
switching gears here
show that and then here's another result
to do with again
complex numbers and conjugates but it's
a bit of a mismatch thing right so you
can see it's not
a complex number times its own conjugate
it's
times the conjugate of some other number
and then you can see another pairing
here
that apparently is equal to 2 times the
real component
of uh you know this this number over
here so that's going to be the second
part
and then prove that uh you know the
modulus of z is greater than or equal to
the real part
of zs so these all seem like preamble
right
none of these seem to explicitly anyway
connect to one another
there's no kind of like hence or
otherwise each of these seems to be kind
of
set up for what we can see is about to
happen in the last two parts
of the question then there's this
diagram in this little
paragraph that introduced the triangle
inequality so
it's called the triangle inequality
because when you've got three sides in a
triangle
like this you can see if this is z and
this is
w then z plus w is is here so you've got
your different moduli that represent
what's going on and uh because you've
got
three signs in a triangle in order for
the sides to connect
uh just suppose you know you had lengths
like oh i don't know
three and five and then you'd say oh i
wonder
what is the length in here right you
know that this length in here
cannot possibly exceed the sum of the
two
other sides it couldn't be say nine
because if you try to do nine then how
would you even create such a triangle
you have to go
three and then the furthest the next
side could go is
five so that three plus five gives you
eight
there's no way you could attach a third
side to that which has a length of
nine because they wouldn't match up
right they wouldn't connect together
all the vertices would never have any
way of joining and uh
sorry all the lengths would have no way
of joining and forming vertices
so you can't have a triangle right so
that's why this inequality tells us
this length here which is modulus for z
plus w
has to be less than or equal to the
modulus of z
plus the modulus of w so that's these
two shorter sides over here as it were
so that's why you've got the
illustration here let's just get rid of
this we don't need that construction
what do we then have to do with this
triangle inequality what we're going to
do is to
prove this result prove that the modulus
of z plus w
is less than or equal to mod z plus mod
w
using all these parts that we just
mentioned up above
can we prove that you know this
inequality here let's just highlight it
in a
different color we want to prove this
inequality and what we want to do
is see these pieces all fitting in
parts one two and three to go into this
particular result
and it's worth noticing by the way the
triangle inequality the way i've
introduced it
seems like it's just to do with like
playing geometry just like euclidean
geometry
and so there is a version of the
triangle inequality which looks much the
same
but it's for real numbers and the fact
that i'm asking you to do it for complex
numbers is part of why
we need to prove it using all of these
complex pieces as it were
and then lastly part five before we
actually get stuck into the solution
says the integer side lengths of a
triangle are given by these three
particular algebraic expressions use the
triangle inequality
this guy here to find the least and
greatest possible values x so
the whole idea is here's the structure
of the question
set up here in parts one to three to
prove the triangle inequality
then in part four we we prove it and
then in part five
we use it we apply it to this particular
problem so
we've got all the pieces in our head now
we're ready to read uh the solution
together
so here's part 1 of 6a
you can see what i've done is as the
question specified i have got
the exponential form of a complex number
so i've got r
e to the i theta r e to the negative i
theta so i'm going to pause right here
and just point out that one of the
common errors in this question
was students erroneously saying well i'm
just going to let z
equal to i uh e to the i theta right now
this
could be a complex number or probably is
but the point is that i have no
r specified out here which means r is
locked into being equal to one
so this can't just be any arbitrary
complex number
this is only complex numbers on the unit
circle
so anyone who did this number one they
simplify what was going on here because
these values here
just became one so it's trivially simple
but in addition to that
you know you're limiting this is not
true for all complex numbers it's just
true for some of them and that's the
problem
right so once you if you were to do it
correctly and set up as r
e to the i theta and r e to the negative
i theta
because of our um index laws here
i've got a common base namely e and then
i've got these two
indices which therefore just add
together so you can see that's why i
just get zero there because
i theta minus i theta is 0. so you've
got it multiplying by 1 in here i
suppose we could write that
that's what e to the 0 is equal to and r
squared is by definition the modulus of
z so you've got rather the modulus we
said all squared so that's why you can
see i've replaced it with mod z squared
as required and then what i've done is
i've said well if that's what z z bar
equals this term here then what i can do
is i can substitute in
z plus w into where i saw z here here
and here
so there's z plus w there's its
conjugate and there is
its modulus squared so
there's result one proved result two we
get asked to move into rectangular form
so here is me
introducing z and w as two different
complex numbers in rectangular form a
plus i b c plus id
you could have called them x plus i y so
long as i've got my real and imaginary
components
components separate in this case what i
need to prove is this result here to do
with uh
z w bar whoopsie daisy z w bar
plus z bar w right so
what i then do is i say well what what
is each of these terms individually can
i substitute each of them
um and then you know multiply through so
you can see here
when i do z w bar there are some terms
that are the same
as z bar w and some terms that are
opposite in signs so
these ones here ac and ac they're the
same i've got b
d b d and then you've also got
i'll do it in red here minus a d
matching with plus a d
and plus i b c matching with minus
i b c so you can see when i add together
line 1 with line 2 or equation 1 with
equation 2
these red underlined terms they just
disappear so that's why there are no
imaginary bits here
and then i get to 2 outside of ac plus
bd
and that by definition if you have a
look it's because i highlighted up above
in orange
ac plus bd that is the real component
of z w bar you can see those are the
bits with no eyes attached to them
so that's why i can do this this
substitution in here because i can see
the ac and the bd
up above okay so that's result two
proved we're still laying foundations at
the moment let's have a look at result
three now this one here was done quite
poorly and that's because there was some
real
um what's the word i'm looking for some
real technical accuracy and precision
required in your use of notation
and in your algebraic manipulation so
let's step through step
uh one step at a time um it probably
helps if we remember
what does the question say because we've
gone a fair way into the question moment
we want to prove that the
modulus of z is greater than or equal to
the real part
of z now a lot of people wanted to make
a fairly intuitive argument for this
and that would have been fine if for
example you'd drawn a diagram that could
really back you up on this
but in most cases a lot of people fell
off the train because they tried to use
algebra
incorrectly let me try and explain what
i mean
we want to start with understanding what
is the
modulus of z in relation to the real
part
of z how can i get that into play well
what i do is i just
write out like this is how we calculate
the modulus of z just using pythagoras
so it's the square root of the
horizontal component vertical component
you know real and imaginary
and then i notice that y is a real
number and this is really
part of the pun this is really really
important lots of people didn't mention
this
right they just went straight to saying
well y
squared has to be greater than or equal
to zero that you know
it's it's a square so therefore it has
to be greater than or equal to zero
and then off i go but this is only true
because y is a real number if y wasn't
real
if y were a complex number then
its squared doesn't necessarily have to
be greater than or equal to zero
that's kind of the entire point of this
topic of complex numbers
that we can square things and they end
up negative that's
the whole jam of a complex number or
imaginary number
specifically so if you did not make any
mention of this
then you were kind of making this
logical claim
that uh y squared's greater than equals
zero but you were not backing it up
because we are in a sphere of
mathematics a field of mathematics
where we know some numbers get squared
and are negative right
so this had to be this substantiation
for this claim was very important
now since y squared is greater than or
equal to 0
when you include it in here it can only
possibly make
this term underneath the square root
sign x squared plus y squared
it can only possibly make it larger
you know it's it could make it you know
stay the same
but it certainly could make it smaller
which is the important part so therefore
you can see i've got this
equality on the boundary that's included
or it's greater than
right because you've got x squared plus
something versus just
x squared so if this itself is
the modulus of z and it's greater than
the square root of x squared
then uh then i can just say the mod z is
greater than
or equal to the square root of x squared
now again this then
led us to the next little bit of
mathematical precision that we need to
look after
the square root of x squared a lot of
people just said that was x
but it's not if x is a negative number
then
the square root of negative 5 all
squared the
square root of negative 5 all squared is
not equal to negative 5 because
we are defining the principal square
root here as only the positive one
right so you cannot simply go from oh
i'm taking the square root of a square
it just undoes everything it just
becomes x it doesn't
it becomes the absolute value of x and
in fact
this is one of the definitions it's the
simplest algebraic definition
for the absolute value of x it's what
happens when you square and then take
the square root
you just get left with the positive
value so you've got here
this is is the correct thing to say from
the square root of
x squared but because what this means is
just take the positive value of this
take its magnitude regardless of whether
it's negative or not
this is likely going to be equal to x if
x is a positive number then the absolute
value of a positive number
is the same as the positive number or if
x is negative then the absolute value of
that will be
obviously larger than the original
number you know the absolute value of
negative 5
is bigger than negative 5. so therefore
you can say well
mod z is bigger than the absolute value
of x that's bigger than x
so therefore if i'm to join the dots you
know you've got the absolute value
of z being bigger than x so that's where
i make this line
in here and of course x by definition
i set it right up here it is the real
part of z so that's how i
get this result as required